um okay so today we'll speak about next
generation sequencing data so hopefully
all of you are familiar with that
already but we'll kind of review some of
the basics we'll talk about what are
some of the viral strains and haplotypes
how do we differentiate different types
of data that we could find information
about these aspects and then what are
some of the comparative strategies for
us to analyze next generation sequencing
data
and what are some of the insights that
we can expect to find
now the u.s government in
inter-agency group developed a variant
classification scheme that defines
three classes of source code ii variants
number one it is variant of of interest
number two variant of concern
and number three
variant of high consequence
okay so let's talk about some examples
b1526 b15261
and b1525 and p2 variants circulating in
the united states are classified as
variants of interest
what that means is that
we
don't know whether they have a
consequence on phenotype but since they
are occurring uh we are going to be
monitoring them right so they are of
interest
the b117 b1351